[Music]
hello and welcome to drive at the motor
magazine coming up Porsches new Panamera
range topper the turbo s with a hybrid
heart lots of room in the Puzo traveler
and the new Skoda karach
the escort artistry Manuel Shaffer
presents the successor to the Skoda Yeti
the car rock he thinks the improved
design should appeal to a wider variety
of tastes now he'll see what else it has
to offer at first glance it could be
confused with a Skoda Kodiak but the new
car rock is more than 30 centimeters
shorter than its big brother and more
than 200 kilograms lighter with a curb
weight of just one and a half tons and
the family resemblance doesn't stop at
the Kodiak the car rock has incorporated
many other features typical of Skoda and
it's VW parent
[Music]
emanuelle mentions Volkswagens modular
transverse engine platform this allows
the various brands within the Volkswagen
group to build their own models based on
this platform for example VW Santi rock
or Seiya to take a range of two
gasoline-powered and three diesel
engines are available for the Quran
without ports from 85 to 140 kilowatts
we tested the two-liter diesel with 110
kilowatts of power with a stick shift it
carried the car up from zero to one
hundred and eight point seven seconds
with a top speed of 196 km/h it'd be
hard to miss the design elements the car
rack has borrowed from the Kodiak no
paternity test needed here the familiar
four-eyed face and Skoda grille dominate
the front as has become the norm in
nearly every segment SCOTUS car rack
features an array of drivers assists and
safety systems predictive pedestrian
protection city emergency brake arc
assist and many others and as is the
case with most of car xcos these assists
come at an extra cost at least the
driver won't have to deactivate them
when they're not needed
[Music]
at the back led tailights insured good
visibility depending on whether the
seats are up or down the cargo space
ranges from 479 to 1810 liters stowage
space and hooks are an added asset the
car rack seats differ from the Kodiaks
Skoda geared them more toward a younger
target group of buyers the interior has
been kept simple but smart with good
workmanship and fine materials a handy
solution for drinks has been integrated
into the car rack center console studs
in the bottle holders allow occupants to
open and close bottles with only one
hand the optional digital instrument
cluster offers a choice of four
different display modes the 9.2 inch
infotainment system supports gesture
control car rock buyers can choose
between the six-speed manual and the
7-speed dual-clutch automatic
transmission all-wheel drive is
available as an option
[Music]
DeNooyer Amanda will notices the
contract absorbs road bumps quite nicely
as an SUV it is set higher and the
suspensions a bit softer and with the
all-wheel-drive on this test car it can
go off-road with no problem in the fun
with 18 centimetres of clearance and a
ramp angle of nearly 20 degrees even
rough roads and big chuckles won't stop
it
an electronically controlled multi-plate
clutch combines data from various
sources such as the RPMs steering angle
and longitudinal and lateral
acceleration for the optimal
distribution of torque
the man was decided that all in all the
car rack is a success it owes quite a
lot to its Big Brother the Kodiak
but it's far more compact and that makes
a difference that enhances dynamics
especially in curves and improves the
chances of finding a parking spot the
car rack starts at under twenty four
thousand three hundred euros in Germany
while a Kodiak will cost at least two
thousand more
[Music]
mr. Claus needs it says if you want a
vehicle that's a sports car and a luxury
sedan and equal measures the Panamera
Turbo S e-hybrid is ideal at Bose 680
horsepower and a top speed of 310
kilometers an hour so to really put the
car through its paces Klaus has brought
it to a Canadian racetrack the launch of
the Panamera for a hybrid made it clear
that electric motors and sporty driving
can go together what's new is that now
the high-end model Panamera Turbo S
e-hybrid also boasts hybrid technology
until now Turbo S designated the
mightiest engine available in a series
now Turbo S and II hybrid are appearing
in combination
with the first Panamera generation
Porsche wanted to show that it's
possible to make a typical Porsche
sports car and a four-door version the
result a coupe a like sedan with ample
legroom even in back the first
generation sub what stumpy rear is
history now the second generation
Panamera has a much more elegant look so
you wonder why not from the get-go
[Music]
the electric motor can turn the Panamera
into a steel thei vehicle but its v8 can
also deliver a roar one that says under
the car's hood is an elaborate high-end
technology a four litre
twin-turbocharged engine then you've got
the 8-speed automatic transmission and
here painted in red is it's electric
motor these two cables carry electricity
from the battery to the front
the electric motor of course also
generates electricity which is then fed
back into the 135 kilogram battery the
entire system produces about 680
horsepower and 850 Newton meters of
torque that's plenty
this is Klaus consuming all of us
Mohammed they seek a scheme to propel
such a car to 100 kilometres an hour and
only three point four seconds require
some serious power the Panamera Turbo S
four litre twin-turbocharged v8 and it's
hybrid module generate assistant
Performance 500 kilowatts and only uses
2.9 liters per 100 kilometers
according to the manufacturer
closest one thing is clear the Panamera
Turbo S e-hybrid really is an amazing
powerful feat of Engineering
that accelerates to 100 in just 3.4
seconds if you really step on it
although that's the ideal scenario even
genuine racing cars struggle to achieve
that and what some Klaus points out that
the electronically regulated and
controlled air suspension makes it
handle almost like a real sports car not
only that says Klaus it also comes with
Porsches famous / infamous all-wheel
drive that ensures perfect balance so
you don't have to worry about
fishtailing Octavia Tasmania and as they
say a good balance are the only hiding
c'mere Gandalf
as for the interior portion offers
features that are already familiar from
the regular turbo a unique feature of
this second generation is the display
and control concept porsche advanced
cockpit as standard fitted has touch
sensitive panels and individually
configured displays in the back there's
more high-end technology the new porsche
rear seat entertainment uses Wi-Fi to
connect the porsche communication
management to access radio media and
vehicle functions with the additional
hybrid motor the Porsche Panamera Turbo
S e-hybrid weighs in at a whopping 2.3
tons that makes it as heavy as a Range
Rover the battery pack alone weighs 130
kilograms its additional electric drive
means an extra 300 kilograms of weight
and that Porsche has called this the
flagship model of the series shows just
how serious Porsche is about going
electric
[Music]
Claes verdict the cars certainly a blast
on the racetrack but if you're honest no
one actually needs 680 horsepower even
though it's nice to own the top range
model lists at around 200,000 euros
gyah is rolling out a new sports sedan
the stinger the car makers fastest
production model has a 3.3 liter v6
gasoline-powered engine and a top
performance of 272 kilowatts it can
sprint from standstill to 100 kilometres
an hour in under five seconds aside from
the top-of-the-line engine he is also
offering the stinger with a 2-liter 188
kilowatt turbo gasoline engine and a
more economical 2.2 liter turbo diesel
with 147 kilowatts Kia's new sports
sedan starts in Germany at around 44
thousand euros this Sun has unveiled its
new generation leaf model the leaf 2.0
edition it's not simply an electric car
with better range it's a mobile power
bank
it's vehicle-to-grid system allows
owners to use the car's bi-directional
battery pack to feed energy into their
homes or offices well equipped with
cutting-edge driver assistance systems
the car emphasizes safety and comfort on
the road
[Music]
after the mazda cx5 s aesthetic and
technical facelift this summer the
Japanese carmaker has introduced an
exciting change under the hood a new top
performance gasoline engine that ushers
in new technology
[Music]
not so it's mr. Ronnie lipsticks as must
has added a high quality gasoline engine
to its range which puts out 143
kilowatts of performance and Ronnie
points to another new high light
automatic cylinder deactivation today
Mazda's SKYACTIV engines have enhanced
performance through an especially high
compression ratio now the car maker has
made mechanical tweaks to the engine
Ronnie explains the turn down brings the
cylinder count down by two while the
turbine keeps spinning a lag destroying
valve system shuts down cylinders one
and four and that quite simply saves
fuel at lower rpm the new engines
performance is impressive delivering
acceleration from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour Sprint's of 9.2 seconds its top
speed is 195 kilometers an hour Mazda
says it's consumption rating is 7.1
liters per 100 kilometers the additional
technology hasn't changed any of the
features typical of a Mazda engine
most is the only major car maker Ronnie
says to dispense with turbochargers on
most of its gasoline engines instead
cooling the high compression four
cylinders with natural aspiration this
is why the engine only really picks up
in the high rev zone achieving a maximum
258 Newton meters at 4000 rpms its
handling and power delivery are nimble
enough to ensure the kind of sporty
driving experience you would expect from
the most powerful engine in the range
[Applause]
does y'all convincing explains the car
makers intention was to keep the noise
level as low as possible so you would
have to have really sensitive hearing
to register the engine noise what's more
noticeable is the low fuel consumption
especially when you're driving at lower
speeds naturally if you're looking for
fuel economy a lot will depend on your
personal driving style casual cruising
is the key to saving fuel
I'm booth Jochen Monsignor says low
speeds achieved the biggest savings at a
constant 40 kilometres an hour the
cylinder deactivation will cut
consumption by about 20 percent at 80
kilometers an hour that figure is still
a respectable five percent Mazda
launched the cx-5 back in 2011 its
recent facelift focused on design
changes at the front including slimmed
down headlights as one of Mazdas most
popular models the cx-5 is paving the
way for engines with cylinder
deactivation and opening up more
possibilities for Mazda in other models
moon singer says it's conceivable that
Mazda could introduce this 2.5 liter
engine with 194 horsepower into other
models as well as integrating the use of
cylinder deactivation and other gasoline
engines across Mazdas range of unburned
fuel torn by matza in the Oscar article
by making further technological strides
Mazda has shown there's still room to
improve
the classic gasoline engine but it all
still comes at a price
Deden asrani points out drivers who opt
for the new gasoline engine because they
don't trust diesel emission values will
have to fork out more at the pump as
well as at their dealers the new
four-cylinder engine is only offered
with four-wheel drive an automatic
transmission and is also only available
in the highest trim line
[Music]
what do asset when space tour
I tell you the price
and a pre-show traveler have in common
10 watts underneath the body they're the
same car which you can tell when you
look at them from behind
our current tester undelete Simo and
wonders of a vehicle that three car
makers have developed jointly can be
flawless who knows if that's the case
manufacture PSA has put the same diesel
engines in the three models our test car
has a 110 kilowatt engine with a
six-speed manual transmission it's the
best of both worlds good driving
performance and fuel efficiency only 5.3
liters per 100 kilometers says the maker
[Music]
Andre says the Puccio traveler is
straightforward and easy enough to
handle what few buttons are there are
the basic ones but Andre doesn't really
like the vehicle's easygoing steering
you can basically steer using just two
fingers even though that's not
necessarily a problem one big advantage
of the Puzo traveller in its siblings
none are higher than 1 meter 90 which
means they can easily enter most parking
garages it's a bit odd when you're
parking the easy steering suddenly turns
stiff when you're stationary or moving
slowly the other way around better in
command
a bird's-eye rear-view camera is
optional
but because the traveller only has one
rear camera the picture only loads up
bit by bit even so together with the
cars parking sensors it's a great
parking aid
[Music]
[Music]
the traveller has a bold look
a lion esque brawny front almost square
it's one meter 92 wide not counting the
rearview mirrors and one meter 90 tall
the different models only vary in length
I make this ugly says the traveler only
comes with a conventional tailgate which
of course is helpful when you're loading
up in the rain but it's awkward in tight
parking spots
ideally Andre would have preferred
scissor doors but those are reserved for
the utility version but the tailgate
does come with one special function the
rear window can be open separately
that's useful for loading smaller items
onto the back shelf
[Music]
cargo capacity varies greatly depending
on how many seats are installed
[Music]
a glass roof panel and 12 and 220 volt
power sockets make the rear interior
seating especially appealing
[Music]
and the front seats come with heating
and a massage function that makes
long-haul journeys much more bearable
[Music]
the traveler Andre says the pugio
traveler does have some quirks but those
are minor issues that don't diminish its
overall quality this cooperative project
between PSA and Toyota has paid off
it's pushed development costs down and
consequently lowered the price for buyer
says Andre fifty thousand euros will buy
you a very well-equipped car you can't
say that about the star in this segment
the BWT six that has a downside of its
own so many versions and extras make
configuring a t6 a mammoth project
that's us configure here and beings that
some traveler
animal would of garbages the basic Cujo
traveler starts at just thirty six
thousand one hundred euros which doesn't
offer as much luxury as our test car but
certainly ample space
[Music]
classic and vintage cars have a certain
elegance and style you just don't see
anymore and they've cast a spell of one
kind or another on their owners part of
it is the challenge and sense of
adventure
the owners set out to experience the
full power of their darlings one way to
do it is with races and performance
tests
other classics fans put more value on
enjoyment and the finer things in life
the vintage car rallies were created for
them on drives like these the journey
itself is its own reward the route for
this year's ADAC land party classic led
through the brave odd and allows its
region south of berlin this was only the
second rally after it's auspicious 2016
premiere in the Lake District around
Reuben
[Music]
you thaw a B C's month would void
confirms that everyone's there to kick
back and enjoy they drive the vintage
cars cross country for an experience
that combines cultural attractions
leisure and automobile fun after all the
ADAC invented the concept of hiking by
car the close to 100 entries in the ADAC
LAN party classic draws crowds
everywhere they go it's like a parade of
highlights from 85 years of automotive
art and the drivers enjoy a stress-free
trip from beautiful countryside
[Music]
this man is glad they don't have to drag
out the roadmap and it's relaxing just
to follow the easy timetable his wife
points out that they have nothing to
argue about it but it isn't always peace
love and harmony once in a while someone
has to let off some steam this man is
having trouble with his cooling system
you'll need the ADAC to help him out a
bit the short breaks are needed to keep
everyone in shape and together at least
the drivers don't have to worry about
points times and valuations the top
priority here is fun and some urbanites
are seeing parts of their country for
the first time this man has been to
nearby caught booze but never explored
its surroundings and or visited the
slave Auto nesco biosphere reserve now
we can appreciate the region's natural
beauty
[Music]
the next break is at noid silla abbey
where participants present their cars in
all their glory to a jury of specialists
in the Concours d'Elegance
[Music]
but no vintage car rally is complete
without a trophy in this case 15
trophies for the best performance tests
and the most outstanding vehicles
[Music]
by the time they cross the finish line
the drivers are completely relaxed and
in the mood to celebrate the classic car
life with good food good music and a
good company and bask in memories of
bygone days
[Music]
that's how this man compares his arrival
in couples to passing a guard of honor
people were lining the streets right and
left as if he were an athlete who'd won
a championship even so he was in a
supporting role because the cars
themselves were in the lead role and he
likes it that way
another points out that they didn't see
any stressed-out teams crossing the
finish line instead they saw people nice
and relaxed headed home after simply
enjoying life for a while that's the
idea behind hiking by vintage car he
says it's a good approach and hopes
organizers will keep the event going and
they've already said next year's route
in 2018 the rally will lead through the
orange spray Lake District
and next time on drive it American
lifestyle we test the Cadillac Escalade
plus a visit to Japan's premier car
event the Tokyo Motor Show
[Music]
[Music]